According to the World Health Organization,
about 347 million people worldwide have diabetes.
Because diabetes treatments are so common
today, it can be easy to forget that the disease
can be fatal.
In fact, it is approximately the seventh leading
cause of death worldwide.
Luckily, many people diagnosed with diabetes
today enjoy healthy, otherwise normal, lives
thanks to advances in treatment, and most
notably insulin.
However, this development is relatively recent,
and only 100 years ago to receive a diabetes
diagnosis was to be condemned to a life of
near starvation and early death.
Known to the ancients, diabetes is one of
the first diseases ever classified.
Both the Vedic-period Indians and the Egyptians
knew it, with the former recognizing it by
the fact that the urine of its sufferers was
so sweet it would attract ants.
Early on, a diabetes mellitus diagnosis was
a death sentence.
By the end of the 1st millennium, its symptoms
were well known: excessive, sweet-tasting
(yes, tasting) urine, excessive thirst, abnormal
appetite and sometimes, even, gangrene.
Early treatments included a mixture of fenungreek,
lupine, trigonnella and zedoary seed, a combination
that is sometimes still used today to reduce
the excretion of sugar.
By the dawn of the 20th century, leading diabetes
specialists were advocating what some called
a starvation diet, “not as a cure, but for
relief of symptoms and maximum extension of
life.”
Hardly a solution, other researchers began
exploring healthier treatments for patients.
One of these was Frederick Banting, a Canadian
doctor.
In 1920, he had the idea that a product could
be extracted from the pancreas that could
be used to reverse the effects of diabetes.
Banting didn’t pull this idea out of thin
air.
Thirty years before, in 1889, two Germans,
a physiologist, Oskar Minkowski, and a physician,
Joseph von Mering, had discovered that the
pancreas regulated glucose.
By conducting several experiments that either
removed the pancreas (from a dog) or tied
off the duct that went from it to the intestine,
they discovered that dogs that had the pancreas
completely removed died from diabetes, but
those who only had the digestive duct ligated
did not develop the condition.
Clearly, they surmised, the pancreas produced
something that prevented diabetes.
Building on this idea, Banting believed that
if a healthy pancreas was deprived of nourishment,
it would lose its ability to make digestive
juices, but its remaining cells could be used
to create an antidiabetic product.
A simple doctor with only a bachelor’s degree,
Banting needed the help of a professional
researcher, and he ultimately enlisted the
aid of University of Toronto professor John
Macleod.
Macleod grudgingly allowed Banting to use
a bit of laboratory space and gave him ten
dogs and an assistant, Charles Best.
In the summer of 1921, Banting and Best first
removed a pancreas from one dog – giving
it diabetes.
Then they “ligated” the pancreas of another,
stopping its nourishment.
After it degenerated, they removed it, chopped
it up, froze it in a special saltwater, ground
it up and injected it into the now-diabetic
dog.
The poor dog improved, and Banting and Best
discovered that a few daily injections kept
the dog healthy.
This finally impressed Macleod who provided
them with more funds and a better lab.
Although Banting and Best initially called
their treatment “isletin,” they deferred
to Macleod’s suggestion of “insulin.”
The name derives from the Latin “insula,”
meaning “island.”
Later in the year, Bertram Collip, a biochemist,
joined the team, and they also switched from
using small dog pancreas to the larger ones
found in cows.
They eventually learned that shrinking the
pancreas was unnecessary, as whole, adult
pancreases worked just fine.
Collip had been brought on to help purify
the insulin and determine the proper dose
for humans.
The first two human guinea pigs were Banting
and Best who injected themselves; although
they suffered from dizziness and weakness,
it otherwise had no ill effects.
During this time, Collip discovered that glucose
helped alleviate the symptoms of an insulin
overdose.
The first diabetic human to try insulin was
Leonard Thompson, a 14-year-old from Toronto
who was near death when they began the trial
in January 1922.
Shortly thereafter, he regained his health.
Another early subject was Elizabeth Hughes,
the daughter of a prominent American, Charles
Evans Hughes, Sr., who at the time was the
U.S. Secretary of State.
(He later went on to become the Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court).
Prior to insulin, Elizabeth was treated with
a starvation diet with only limited success.
By 1922, she had dropped to 45 pounds (she
was about 5 feet tall), and her mother pleaded
with Banting until Elizabeth was allowed to
participate in the trial.
Also a success, Elizabeth ultimately went
on to lead a long, full life.
By 1923, the world realized what Banting,
Best and Collip had discovered with Macleod’s
help, and the Nobel Committee awarded Banting
and Macleod the Nobel Prize in Physiology
or Medicine.
Banting was angry that Macleod, and not Best,
was included in the prize.
In later years, the committee has justified
its award to Macleod, rather than Best and
Collip, by noting that Macleod provided financial
and other support for the project, supervised
the work and used his connections to get the
discovery known among the larger scientific
community.
In the end, Best and Collip received recognition,
at least from Banting and Macleod, who shared
their cash awards with their over-looked colleagues.